Y'all want more of this, shitty GAME???
Y'all enjoyed it so much last time I played it,
So WHY NOT make another one?!
The comments, are practically, BEGGING FOR IT
Let's see who else played this game, OH THATS RIGHT
FUCKIN' EVERYONE
Oh look there's money in the background,
WHAT A CREATIVE AND ORIGINAL IDEA
Where could you have possibly gotten it from?
But I'll play some more, I'll have some fun,
WE'LL HAVE SOME LAUGHS
*epic pause*
*sniggers* anyway lets play some more, *more laughing*
Looks like Pewdiepie's depressed again,
He stares at the games... he's like, staring into the void
Another fucking video he thinks,
*fart noise*
.... What the fuck is that sound?!
IT'S TRIGGERIN' ME
AwrightawrightAWRIGHTAWRIGHT
Gotta come up with a good title,
Let's just call it what it is!
OH, we gotta make a video!
Let's do a- mugheh, THE CLASSIC, MURDEROUS LOOK!
(said murderous look)
SARCASTIC COMMENT!
Hey everyone, Leafy here, I'm going to kill myself tonight.
That's all we have time for, okay let's edit this baby.
Literally I do the same shit just THROW that shit together,
No one gives a shit
OOOH publish that shit!
"Frederick, do you wanna chat?" Okay
Haww look, we might find like a meme here,
"Videogame Company Buys, Cats"
*clap* HAHAHAHA,
What am I doing? oh yeah I'm waiting for the video to render,
Why am I not tabbing out, and watching porn?
Really interesting, what a surprise!
"Who edited this video, hahahahaha, it's so bad"
Elise
Never fuck with a guy that... knows PHOTOSHOP
OH WHAT A NICE, COWBOY HAT, ELISE,
OH WAIT, IT'S A DICK
What is Pewdiepie doing?
Pewdiepie...
*click click*
Pewdiepie you gotta make another video,
"But I don't wanna make another video!"
"I just wanna play games for fun!"
(Nobody understands me music)
SHUT THE FUCK UP PEWDIEPIE MAKE ANOTHER FUCKING VIDEO
Oh GAWD I gotta make another video of horrific, Horrifying Sewer
(saddest music ever to music)
Now at least that's an honest title,
*schwing*
"Dancing greeting"
Aw I got that one,
HeHEY, how's it going bros?! :D *slurp*
whatamidoing
That's it, that's all I have time for... what a piece of shit video
Oh man this recording didn't really turn out well...
Maybe I should... scrap it, and try again
*pause*
*fart noise* psh... HAAAAHAHAHAHA
...
That's hilarious
These peasants will watch, what I give them
lol
*more of the saddest music*
Okay so you can see how popular the games are,
Okay we're just gonna pick the most popular game to play,
Because FUCK having your own personality and adding value
Wait wha- WHAT. Grand Tarisma go- di- got released?!
Holy, SHIT
I GOTTA GET A VIDEO OUT, RIGHT, FUCKING, NOW!
THE SOONER THE VIDEO GETS UP, THE MORE VIEWS I'll get,
'Cuz fuck quality...
Okay, UHHM.. wait, pfehuh, wait, hello
Hows it goin' bros?
MURDEROUS LOOK
(... said murderous look)
Oh God, uh, uhmuh, lloading, ffunny uh, s- scrimmy
(mating call to Marzia)
Funny comments :)
I have a micropenis
(Youtube anger)
Why's mom staring there so awkward?
She's just standing there,
Fuck off, Mom!
(moan)
OH-
SHIT
OH GOD NO We FAILED OUR GRADES
OH GAWD
MOM IS GONNA BE SO SUPER PISSED
My life is over
GO to sleep, go to sleep fast, SHIT
NO. NO. NO! NO!
NO! MOM!
PLEASE!
I'M LOSING SUBSCRIBERS MOM, YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
I wanna be poodiepie wan dae mohm
Why would you play this game unironically?
Alright, it;s time to move out
Fuck you mom, you're not gonna- ruin my career
I don't even say goodbye
Ah shit now we gotta pay for our own food and shit,
ENERGY DRINKS. LOOOOOT AND LOOOTA ENERGY DRINKS
YOU THINK I ACTUALLY HAVE A PERSONALITY?
Kay we gotta add as many tags to the title as possible,
'Cos more tags in the title, means more views
Gameplay, Walkthrough, Let's Play, Playthrough, Tutorial, Play Let's, 1080p, 60fps,
Like anyone gives a shit,
HD, GONE SEXUAL
(best title ever)
Ooh we're playing a horror game
Uh, let's do aa, music intro
(singing) Hooows it goin' broos myyy name is pew-
I do this for a living, you can tell, right?
Come on this game is not even realistic, where's the part about obsessing about analytics?
And looking at the stats about how many views you got?
Go to sleep. Wake up. Make a video. Repeat.
Every.
FUCKING.
SINGLE.
DAY
It's funny because I'm just using this game to call out all the bullshit lol
See? Even if the game isn't that funny, I can still have fun with it.
Even if a video is different everyday, I have a fanbase, that accept the videos, regardless.
And I appreciate that cause that gives me a lot of freedom,
And, makes me happy :)
So thank you so much for watching another video,
Don't forget to like, subscribe,
G- and Google+, Facebook, Twitter and Pinterest,
Thank you so much, (fist kiss)
And as always, Stay Awesome Bros!
I'M SURE THAT EVERYONE WHO PLAYED THIS GAME IS PLAYING IT, BECAUSE THEY THINK IT'S A REALLY GOOD GAME AND NOT BECAUSE ITS GONNA GET A LOT OF CLICKS ON YOUTOOBE
BECAUSE OF THE TITLE OF THE GAME, AND YOO TELL ME RIGHT NOAW, THAT THAT IS NOT A CO-